all right let's begin then looking at
today's topic which you can see they're
heading up the top by thinking of
something you haven't looked at for a
while and since has nothing to do with
anything really what is this what's it's
called it's called auxiliary angle right
or subsidiary angle or some natural
supplementary or all kinds of things
what was this about this is about
looking at a sum or a difference of two
trig functions right sign of the college
and then we rephrased it like this what
was different there's three things I can
see that are different on this side from
that so shout out an obvious one there's
an R okay that wasn't the thing I was
thinking this myth obvious that's okay
I've got a recognition that the
amplitude over here will not be the same
as the individual amplitudes over on the
left-hand side okay that's something
different what else okay so there's a
guy here after which this method is
named this is the auxilary angle in
Orgel
okay the most obvious thing about this
hasn't been mentioned is it kinda
typically what happened you went from
two functions to one and the way that we
went from two to one is by inserting
these things okay now what was the point
of this there were two one of them was
sort of the practical point and then one
of them the other one was kind of a bit
sort of big picture right the practical
point was when you rephrase something
like this in this way you can solve a
bunch of problems that you never could
before right like if I asked you to
solve sine X plus cos x equals 1 you'd
be you'd sort of scratch your head a
little bit and think well what do I do
with that it's not impossible to solve
it's just kind of don't know what to do
sorry oh
out of interest if you didn't know
exerting go what would you do with this
draw a graph not a bad way to go I you
would have to then of course have to
work out what sine X plus cos x looks
like that would be okay not easy but
okay anything else you could do yeah you
could square a receipt now that's a good
way to go in terms of what we've been
learning recently because we've been
team out quadratic functions a lot right
just let me just have a look what would
actually happen what would you get on
the right-hand side when you squared
that's that's good what would you get on
the left-hand side you'd get sine
squared plus cos squared plus 2 yeah
sine X close X now very conveniently if
you have a look at that have a look at
left hand side that's sine squared plus
cos squared I've separated out can you
see why that might be a good idea what
is same scale plus cos squared equal to
X equal to 1 so very conveniently those
cancel out which leaves you with this
whoops
equals 0 which means that this equals 0
and you can actually get consult that
country you have to be careful you have
to be careful because from line 1 to
line 2 when we square everything you've
got to be you know cautious with what
that does to your equation when we've
done that in the past what has that done
to the solutions when you squared
everything it's um it's often added more
solutions do you remember that so if we
had solutions out of this not all of
them may be solutions to the original
question but doable right however that
is something of a coincidence you can
see I can muck with these numbers very
simply and you won't get this nice
collapse happening on the left hand of
the right hand side so that was just
luck really
now I said that that was the practical
reason we do this so that now we can
solve more questions ok but as a sort of
broader mathematical thing the
is a perfect example the reason why it's
in the course is not so that you can
solve these press questions because when
you get out in the real world even if
you're an engineer or an architect Solar
is actually going to solve questions
like this you'll get a computer to do
this you would crunch through it what we
want you to get is when you take a
simple single object and what's this
going to look like I think it's going to
look something like this
ish okay when you take a single object
and you look at it from two different
angles same object but you just kind of
like pivot a little bit a bit like
looking at a diamond if you've ever seen
a gem before of any kind when you move
it a little bit it looks like a whole
different object like if the light
refracted it all looks crazy but it's
the same thing and you gain insights
about how it works when you look at it
from two different perspectives right
and that is what today's topic within
quadratics is about okay so underneath
this I want you to consider this
quadratic here which is of course could
be any quadratic given different values
of a B and C now look excuse me general
for this we've discussed before it's not
particularly revealing it doesn't show
you very much about the structure or the
shape of the proper you've got to muck
with it in order to do that for example
if you wanted to find out what the
vertex was what might be the simplest
way to do it there's lots of ways but
give me one say it again
okay you go straight to the axis of
symmetry by using these two coefficients
here and then what would you do with
that you'd pop it back in okay that's
fine
I could also rephrase this equation I
could put it into a form that makes the
vertex obvious right what skill what I
have to use I have to complete a square
that would a rearrangement see I'd get
something that looks a little more like
I mean if this was a why does it change
that it's fine if this is a why I would
get something like this
like so okay and what will be the
conclusion from this where would I say
the vertex is have a look it'd be are
you get the x coordinate from here
should be H and then you get the y
coordinate for rias would be H comma K
right so that's fine that gets you to
vertex what if you wanted the roots or
if you wanted the roots where would you
um how would you work with this thing
you could do the quadratic formula
because you don't know anything about a
B and C whether it's nice to factorize
or not but if you can factorize that
would be nice because just like this
from the factorized form you can easily
read off what the roots are okay now the
factorized form of this i'm going to go
back to the zero the factor is form of
this I can predict what it will look
like assuming that there are roots let
me before I produce what it looks like I
want to ask him at this number here why
do I have to put a number there there's
a lot of parabolas quadratic to deal
with don't have a number there it's just
X minus H or squared what's that about
think about it why does there have to be
an a there if this is what I started
with seriously niacin yeah over here
right if there's an A here for these two
things to be equivalent then there has
to be an A over here as well okay so now
keep that knowledge in mind and think
about what this would look like if it
were factorize good morning
oh yeah be on top
now remember don't know anything about
what the roots are because you don't
know what a B and C are for all you know
there might not even be roots we'll come
back to that question in a second but if
you were to factorize it would look
something like this one or not or would
you put in the brackets if it were
factorize it would be x + or take away
something and x + or take away something
else right okay now remember I don't
know what any of these things are so I'm
going to give them some names these two
things here are going to be the roots
the customary name for the roots are
alpha and beta okay so we use them not
just for angles introductory geometry we
also use them for the roots of a
quadratic function okay
now this thing will have two roots alpha
and beta but these three things aren't
going to be equal unless a is going to
be one do you notice that because look
if I expand this out how many X
Squared's will I get exactly one so just
like over here how am I going to fix
that up what will I do I should make
sure just like all of these guys I have
a coefficient of a at the front okay so
this is the diamond and this or these
are the two perspectives on the diamond
right if these two things really are the
same object I should be able to gain
some insights from the by looking at
both and comparing them in fact that's
what we did up with auxiliary angle do
you remember that so this guy over here
on the right-hand side you can expand
this this is one of the things we learn
is extension one student what is the
expansion of sine X or cellphone sine X
cos alpha plus
because X sine alpha you could put in
any order of course because they are
just in a product we tend to try and
keep the angles nudged up so I put my
X's and then I've got my office okay so
when we did this we noticed oh look
there's site X's on the right hand side
and there's selections on the left and
they must be equivalent yeah
in the same way there are Claude X's on
the right and there are client X's on
the left
they must be equivalent as well and we
named this process comparing
coefficients do you remember that you're
like coefficient of U coefficient over
here it's the same object remember so
these must match up I'm going to play
this same game with these two guys right
if they really are the same object then
I should be able to say that ax squared
plus BX plus C I'm a little call your
might back to you trig again because
when we say two things have to be
exactly identical to each other we don't
just call that an equation we call that
an identity so I'm going to put in three
lines here okay this indicates that this
thing over the right hand side it's not
just equal sometimes it's equal all the
time irrespective of the values that I
put in here okay so remember alpha and
beta are the roots of introduces in we
know what a B and C are they're just the
coefficients give you numbers all right
let's see what happens here
now the first thing I want to do is try
to get rid of these aids remember when
we did completing the square it's just
finicky to deal with quadratics when
they're non modoch right so I'm going to
divide everything through by a that
looks on the left hand side like it
makes things worse because I'm going to
introduce fractions in a second but go
with me because it's going to make the
right-hand side much easier to deal with
okay
okay